[Music]
at least 200 people have been confirmed
dead after Cyclone Moka hit the coast of
Myanmar on Sunday the news has taken
several days to get out after
Communications to the Northwestern town
of situa were knocked out camps housing
hundreds of thousands of displaced
rohingya Muslims were badly hit as our
correspondent Tony Chang reports
a confidence carried out of a rohingya
camp on the edge of situway in Northwest
Myanmar another victim of cyclone Moka
that's reported to have killed hundreds
of people when it hit on Sunday night
in the light of day the full Devastation
caused by the storm is clear flimsy
structures that are home to hundreds of
thousands of ethnic rohingya displaced
by myanmar's military no match for winds
in excess of 200 kilometers per hour
there were many people who got wounded
due to the storm even around this place
some got wounds in legs and hands many
died
when the storm got stronger I ran away
from this place with my children as I
did not want to die but we sang in the
water and people saved us by pulling us
out
the tropical Cyclone left widespread
damage in its wake
fishing boats are vital part of the
economy piled up like fresh Tinder along
the coast many buildings with more
sturdy structures now without roofs
windows or doors
the area has been cut off since Sunday
with roads blocked and Communications
down people here told Al Jazeera there's
very little Aid relief and Medical
Services have stopped
Myanmar State tv showed senior General
Minong Lai inspecting damage in the area
on Monday
official sources had said only three
people died in the storm
that number's likely to rise sharply as
communication lines are restored
in neighboring Bangladesh where more
than one million rohingya refugees live
in camps repairs are already underway
it's a huge strain on people with such
limited resources although many feared
it could have been worse
and it's a devastating blow both for
those displaced and those who remained
at home Tony Chang Al Jazeera
while Sharif Ahmad is the head of
programs for Myanmar and Bangladesh at
Islamic relief worldwide he says to
space people in that region are
especially vulnerable to extreme weather
events
in that kind of state you know it's a
conflict Zone area and people are all
socioeconomic condition is is very poor
so their housing condition and other
facilities also not so strong there is a
massive distraction happened in IDP
camps
situated in
Township areas as well as another
Township parked areas as well as rural
communities you know around 600 000
rohingya communities also living in
rural areas so there is a massive damage
happen in rural people houses also and
in IDP camps hundred percent uh idb
shelters Roofing of their shelters
damaged
but some houses are collapsed around 10
to 15 percent this water SARS actually
washed away most of the people's
belongings so they desperately need food
now and then also then it NFS like
kitchen utensil we have to support for
their worst facilities
as well as uh we have to look into their
children and women protection and safety
issues also so right now
no one can reach there with vehicle
there is only way to go there with
motorcycle because the road are not
fully cleared yet